police in new york city and washington
d.c are working with their federal
counterparts to look for a suspect
linked now to multiple shootings of
homeless people in both of those cities
five people overall have been shot since
march third two of those people killed
and last night another homeless person
was found dead in manhattan police are
working to determine the cause of death
and whether that incident is related to
the others but nancy chan has put
together the latest on the investigation
and we should warn you that some of the
images in her report
are disturbing
if you had any kind of interaction in
these areas this morning we strongly
encourage you to please report it
authorities in new york city are
offering a 10 thousand dollar reward to
find this man who they say is
responsible for two shootings on
saturday morning that killed one
homeless man and left another injured
the nypd says the first victim a
38-year-old hispanic male was sleeping
on a corner when a person came up and
shot him in the right arm the victim
then screamed at the suspect as he fled
the victim is recovering in the hospital
less than two hours later police say the
same man seen in this surveillance video
approached a second homeless man also
sleeping on a lower manhattan street
just blocks away the suspect lingers
over the man nudging him a few times
before opening fire striking the
unidentified man in the head and neck
the victim was later pronounced dead at
the scene
those shootings came as the metropolitan
police department in washington on
sunday alleged the suspect's attacks on
homeless men started in their city d.c
police say three homeless individuals
were shot over a period of six days
starting march 3rd one fatally
yesterday the mayors of both new york
and washington d.c released a joint
statement urging all homeless persons to
seek shelter as law enforcement works to
track down what they call a cold-blooded
killer on the loose adding our
communities in d.c and new york city are
heartbroken and disturbed by these
heinous crimes in which an individual
has been targeting some of our most
vulnerable residents
and last night police here in new york
city found another deceased homeless man
this time in the tribeca neighborhood
police say they had warned the victim
earlier in the day that two homeless men
had been attacked here in lower
manhattan the previous night it's not
yet clear if his death is connected to
the other incidents
tony
we got pretty good pictures of the
suspect there i hope someone recognizes
that individual nancy thank you very
much